Skies Ivor Bennett joins me now either a
lot of concern about what happened to
this poor woman because you know people
are passing by horse riders saw what was
happening what does the inquest being
told yeah the inquest opened this
morning and we got some more detail
about the way in which Natasha Johnson
died the 28 year old woman who was more
to death by dogs in Surrey earlier this
month and I should say that that detail
is quite graphic and quite distressing
the coroner Simon wickens said that Miss
Johnston died after receiving multiple
penetrating bites to the neck he also
said she suffered shock and Hemorrhage
including a wound to her jugular vein
the attack happened on January the 12th
and the Gravelly Hill area of Caterham
it's a well-known Beauty Spot in the
area popular with dog walkers and the
coroner confirmed this morning that Miss
Johnston was a professional dog walker
and she is believed to have been walking
several dogs at the time of the attack
we still don't know much about the dogs
themselves we know that eight were
seized by police at this seen and they
remain in police custody as forensic
investigations on the animals continue
but sorry police have confirmed already
that none of the dogs were banned breeds
under the dangerous dogs act
there was also a criminal investigation
that finished last week with police also
confirming that there will be no
prosecutions over this attack but there
there is an inquest into the death of
Miss Johnston the coroner said this
morning because of the traumatic nature
of her injuries and he also offered his
sincere condolences to her to a family
before adjourning the inquest until June